[موسيقى]
صادف فارس اعرابيا في الصحراء يحفر في
الرمال حفرا عديده وبقلق شديد ساله لما
تفعل ذلك فاجابه انه كان قد دفن بعض المال
في هذا المكان وهو يبحث عنه الان دون جدوى
الم تضع علامه ترشدك اليه يا رجل سال
الفارس فرد الاعرابي بلى وكانت العلامه
غيمه في السماء لكنني اضعتها
سيبدو لنا الاعرابي نادرا في غبائه لكننا
لو تاملنا قليلا لوجدنا الكثيرين منا وقد
استثمروا حياتهم ووضعوا اهدافهم متعلقين
بامور عابره لا ترشد الى الكنز الحقيقي
فالغيوم وان كثرت ستمضي وتبقى السماء الى
العناوين
قبل مئات السنين صلاح الدين الايوبي حمى
الكنائس الارمينيه في القدس
ظاهره المساكنه بين الجنسين المخالفه
للاديان تغزو اكثر من بلد عربي
باسيوس توقع حربا عالميه تحتل فيها روسيا
تركيا وتصر الصين الى العراق
حفلات الطلاق تنافس حفلات الاعراس في
لبنان
وتنظمها شركات متخصصه
جرائم الخطف بهدف طلب فديه وصلت الى جثث
الموتى في مصر
[موسيقى]
مرحبا واهلا بكم الى حلقه خاصه ومتنوعه
بعيدا عن رزنامه الاسبوع هناك منطق اشتغل
على ترويجه في بعض الدول العربيه يعتقد ان
مصادره اجنبيه وتهدف الى زرع الفتن
الطائفيه بين ابناء الوطن الواحد هذا
المنطق غير منطقي يسعى الى تخويف الاقليات
المسيحيه على وجودها وكنائسها من الاغلبيه
الديموغرافيه المسلمه لماذا هذا المنطق
غير منطقي لان المسلمين مروا بعهود قوه
عظمى خلال مئات من الاعوام الماضيه وبقيت
كنائس المسيحيين تحت حكمهم تمارس دورها
والناس تتعايش بسلام قبل ان تحتل اوروبا
المنطقه
فلسطين كانت دوما فوق الطائفيه المستورده
الباحث المتخصص في تاريخ القدس داوود
مارينيوس يتحدث بمعلومات لا يعرفها الجميع
عن حمايه السلطان صلاح الدين الايوبي
الكنائس والثقافه الارمينيه في القدس كما
نرى
في مدخل البطريركيه الارمنيه كتابه
بالنقش العربي الكوفي وهي حمايه المكان من
السلطان المظفر صلاح الدين الايوبي
يعلو تعلو سبيل ماء يرجع الى الفتره
العثمانيه العهده العمانيه بتذكر وجود
الارمن كفئه موجوده من فئات القدس والهم
احقيه الزياره من 1099
بدا عنا وجود حاره خاصه او منطقه خاصه
للارمله اليوم احنا بنسميها حاره الارمله
حاره الارمن حاليا
بشكلها اللي احنا شايفينه برجع للفتره
الصليبيه
لانه من 1999 ل 1187 في الفتره الصليبيه
تواجدوا الارمن في هذه المنطقه فلما اجا
صلاح الدين حمى الدير وحمل كنيسه
وابقى الارمن موجودين فيها الى يومنا هذا
ليست فقط بريطانيا تمنع وصول ملك الى
عرشها لا يعتنق الديانه المسيحيه بل
الارجنتين ايضا بحسب الباحث عبد الواحد
اكبير الذي يذكر ان الرئيس الارجنتيني
الاسبق كارلوس منعم وهو من اصول سوريه
مسلمه اعلنت تحوله الى المسيحيه ليتمكن
بالفوز برئاسه الارجنتين التي يمنع
دستورها وصول شخص غير مسيحي الى الرئاسه
كالروس من علم نفسه حاله معبره في بيتهم
كانت تقاليد الاسلاميه ابواه يصليان
يصومان الان لما ترشح الانتخابات الرئاسيه
في الارجنتين الدستور الارجنتيني يقول
رئيس الدوله يجب ان يكون من الديانه
المسيحيه اعلن انه مسيحي من اجل المصلحه
الاسماء الاسلاميه لم تكن لتسجل في دوائر
الدوله الرسميه بالارجنتين في ثلاثينيات
القرن الماضي التقيت بشخص مسلم فوجدت اسمه
امادو فقلت له هذا الاسم لا علاقه له
بالاسلام وكان هاجر في ثلاثينات القرن
العشرين قال لي انا اسمي الاصلي هو احمد
الحداد فقط لما وصل الى ميناء بنصيرس
وسجلوا اسمه قال له احمد احنا ليسنا عندنا
في هذا السجل اسم احمد سنبحث لك عن اقرب
اسم لاحمد وامادو قال له حدد طيب ما تعني
كلمه حداد بالاسبانيه فبدا يشرح لهم فهي
فاصبح اسمه امادور ريرو العنصريه الطائفيه
في بعض الدول العربيه هي في الغالب حصاد
ما زرعه الاحتلال الاوروبي عقب الحرب
العالميه وتقسيمه الشرق الاوسط بلديه
الحدث في لبنان
او تاجيره او بيعه غير المسيحيين اي شقه
او غرفه في منطقه حكمها العنصري وقد تم
ذلك في حينه بغطاء رسمي على ذمه رئيس
البلديه الذي يفاخر علنا بقراره الفقره
طاء من مقدمه الدستور تنص حرفيا على
التالي ارض لبنان ارض واحده لكل
اللبنانيين فلكل لبناني او حق في الاقامه
على اي جزء منها والتمتع به في ظل سياده
القانون فلا فرز للشعب على اساس اي انتماء
كان ولا تجزئه ولا تقسيم ولا توطيم لكن
القواعد في بلديه الحدث تتعارض وهذا النص
الذي اقسم عليه رئيس الجمهوريه يفاخر رئيس
بلديه الحدث جورج عون بقراره ويعلن انه
قرار مدعوم من القيادات المسيحيه
والاسلاميه ايضا ممنوع المسيح به نعم قررت
مسيحي بيع مسلم
وهذا نحن فخورين فيه بكل فخر
حفاظا على العيش المشترك حفاظا على
التغيير الديموغرافي ممنوع التغيير
الديموغرافي معنى من الحداثيين تاييد عام
في من فخامه الرئيس تاييد عام في من دوله
الرئيس بري تقييد عن في من سيد حسن نصر
الله تقييد عام في كله الاديان تقريبا لا
تعترف بغير الزواج القانوني وترفض اي
علاقه خارج المؤسسه الزوجيه هذه العلاقه
غير الشرعيه وفق الاديان روجت لها الحضاره
اللاتينيه في الغرب تحت عنوان المساكنه
المغني اللبناني يوري مرقدي وزوجته الفت
منذر اللذان يعلنان دائما انهما لا دينيين
بل ضد الاديان يعلنان ايضا انهما عاشا معا
حياه زوجيه كامله قبل الزواج بل يقولوا ان
ابنته تعيش الان نفس التجربه ولو لم تكن
تساكن
لدفعها دفعا الى المساكنه وقد شبهوا
الزواج
بالبطيخه لا تشترى الا بعد شقها بالسكين
عملت موسيقى شو هالفكره الزواج يلي شغله
مصيريه واساسيه ملايين السنين يلي ما عندك
خبره واحد بالميه لما تفوتي فيها
يعني
عامله موسيقى
بلبنان كنت قبلت
كنت دفشتك كنت قلتلها اذا بتروحي بزبطي
حالك بايدين رجال لا بتعرفيه ولا بتعرفي
عاداته بينام ولا بياكل بيشرب ولا كيف
بنرفز الفت وانا نحن شخصين منا متدينين
اثنيناتنا ضد الدين هذه الثقافه ليست
عربيه لا من قريب ولا من بعيد لكن الاغنيه
التي اطلقت نجوميه يوري مرقده كانت عربي
انا
احببتني ومن تونس ناشط محلي معروف يظهر في
احد البرامج بشكل غريب بعض الشيء ليطالب
العائله التونسيه بالتخلص من مفهوم الزنا
فالاخ يتبنى ثقافه البطيخه طلع ليش مع
المعاشره قبل الزواج معناتها
قبل ما يعرسوا يقفزني كل واحد يعرف شكون
عنده شكون ما عندوش
العواشر اللي جاء اكبر غلط
نحن البشر ظلمنا الحمير كثيرا وحولناها
الى اله نقل وخدمه بلا حقوق ثم اذا اراد
احدهم ان يشتم اخر يقول له يا حمار
جديد التنكيل بالحمير تجهيزها في اكثر من
مكان للذبح بهدف الاكل مع انها لم تخلق
لتؤكل ربه اسره مصريه ريفيه تمسك بحمارها
وتقسم انه لم يعد امامهم الا ان يذبحوه
وياكلوه مع ارتفاع الاسعار
اليوم فعلا اللي بدل ما ناكل لحم البهايم
اللي بقى ب 300 جنيه اللي بقت 300 جنيه
هيجي علينا اليوم بدل ما ناكل لحمه
البهايم هناكل اقسم بالله لحم الحمير يبقى
اذا الحمار المخطط يجوز اكله
[موسيقى]
يتناقلوا الاوروبيون باهتمام اللافت
تكهنات بايثيوس رجل الدين والمنجم في ان
معا الذي توفي عام
رئيس هذا توقع حربا عالميه ثالثه تمحو
اوروبا عن الخريطه وتحتلوا فيها روسيا
تركيا ويشرب مئتان مليون صيني من نهر
الفرات قبل وصولهم الى القدس بفلسطين وقد
كذب المنجمون وكتروا مئت مليون صينيين
يعبرون نهر الفرات ويصلون في القدس روسيا
تحتل تركيا وتمحيها من خارطه العالم
بصواريخ نوويه
وتقسمها الى دويلات صغيره ثلث الاتراك
سيكونون مسيحيين ويموت الثلث اما الثلث
الاخير فسيذهب الى بلاد ما بين النهرين
الشرق الاوسط سيتحول الى ساحه لسفك الدماء
تكون رو فيها اللعب الرئيسي الحرب
العالميه الثالثه ستبدا من اوروبا ونهايه
العالم تبدا من الصين بانفجار ضخم نبوءات
قالها رجل توقع من ذي قبل انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي وخروج بريطانيا عن الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقال ان ذلك سيكون بدايه نهايه
لاوروبا والغرب فمن هو
القديسبايسيوس الاثوسي صاحب هذه التوقعات
المنجم اللبناني مايكاف غاليه ايضا سبق ان
تكهن وتوقع ان يكون لبنان جنه العالم
لبنان يبدا دخول تيكون جنه العالم
واللي شايفهم باوروبا على لبنان ان شاء
الله
ما يجوا لاجئين تسرب نووي بمكان ما بده
ياسرع اوروبا في منطقه بتصير مثل الشب كيف
مدينه الاشباح اللي ما فيها شيء نحن لوين
رايحين
طبعا اجهنم من ابرز تاثيرات انهيار الليره
على الاسره اللبنانيه هو اتساع واقع
العنوسه والابتعاد عن الزواج لاكلافه
الفلكيه بالنسبه لذوي الدخل المحدود فكيف
مع بروز ظاهره غير مالوفه وهي حفلات
الطلاق يعني قريبا في لبنان المحكوم نسبيا
بكثير من المظاهر ما يريد ان يتزوج عليه
ان يحسب حساب حفله العرس ثم حفله الطلاق
اذا لم يحصل للتوفيق وبدل الحفله حفلتين
للمطلق والمطلقه كي لا يقال انها او انهما
مقهوران بسبب الطلاق وقد باتت الشركات
المتخصصه باحياء الاعراس تقدم ايضا خدمه
تنظيم حفلات الطلاق للراغبين حفله طلاق من
هذا النوع اقامتها مؤخرا عائله لبنانيه
بمناسبه انفصال ابنتها عن زوجها وقد
احياها فنان محلي معروف مع فرقته
الموسيقيه بحضور الاقارب والاصدقاء تحت
لوحه كبيره كتب عليها عباره
مطلق للتو
راح
الدنيا كثيرون يتعرضون للسرقه في حياتهم
لكنهم قلائل اولئك الذين تعرضوا للسرقه
وهم في قبورهم الطول القصه عصابه متخصصه
بسرقه جثم الموتى الاثرياء وتهديد
عائلاتهم برميها في البحر اذا لم يسددوا
لهم فديه مليونيه في واقعه غريبه هي
الاولى من نوعها الحبس ثلاث سنوات لمتهمين
بسرقه رفات متوفى من قبره وطلب فديه نصف
مليون جنيه من اسرته مقابل اعادتها والا
سيرمون الرفاه في البحر اصدرت محكمه طلخا
بمحافظه الدقهليه حكم بالحبس لمده ثلاث
سنوات على ثلاث ملتهبين في قضيه هي الاغرب
من نوعها وهي سرقه رفات متوفى ومساومه
ابناءه على دفع مبلغ نص مليون جنيه من اجل
اعادته ليهم مره ثانيه وطبعا هم كانوا
عارفين ان اهل المتوفى من ميسوري الحال
حسين الميس معمر تونسي يقول انه كان يسد
رمقه حين يجوع بما يتوفر من حسائش الارض
ونباتاتها العم حسين يحتفل هذا العام بعيد
ميلائه وتسعه عشر دون ان يعاني من اي
مشاكل صحيه تذكر بحسب افاده الطبيب الفحص
القلب وكان ممتاز جدا
وحتى الدواء عنده شويه ضغط الدم بابسط
دواء تقريبا متوفر
في غيبه وكل شيء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تقول دراسه امريكيه ان تاثير خطابك على
الاخرين يعتمد بنسبه سبعه بالمئه فقط على
محتوى ما تقوله اما الثلاثه وتسعون بالمئه
من التاثير فيعتمد على اسلوبك في صياغه
الكلام وسرده في مدينه النبطيه بلبنان زاد
انتاج محل لتصليح الاحذيه بنسبه 70% بعد
تغيير صاحبه كلمه على لافته اسم المشغل
الخارجيه فما هو هذا الاختراع الذي انقذ
المحله من الاغلاق هو كان اسمه بالاول محل
تصليح احذيه
لكن
حبينا نتميز عننا نحن ابتكرت هذا الاسم
جذب لي الزبائن بشكل قوي نسبه الشغل بنسبه
70% صارت تترسخ باذن الزبون انه في مستشفى
من خمسين عام تقريبا
في خياطه وبتشتغل على الايد وخياطه يدويه
خياطه مكانات توسيع احذيه ودهان
اكسسوارات للاحذيه كمان
حلوه ومرتبه
ومتعرفك على الناس اكثر
بتحبب الناس فيك اكثر وانت بتحب الناس
اكثر عرفوا قيمتها هلا اكتر لما بلشت
الحرب وبلشت الحرب الاقتصاديه على البلد
في مصر صاحب العجله الستيني هو الاب
المثالي الذي يسابق الزمن والمسافه بين
المنزل والجامعه ليوصل ابنته ايه حمدي الى
قاعه المحاضرات والامتحان وسالته عن شيء
جميل اسمحوا لي اقول له
ايه يا حمدي وهي بتقرا قصيده كتبتها عن
والدها مين ايه يا حمدي ممكن تكونوا
شفتوها في الفيديو ده اللي انتشر على
السوشيال ميديا بعنوان اب يوصل بنته
الجامعيه على العجله
مع انها مش باينه بوشها ولا هي ولا والدها
لكن الفيديو لمس اكتر من خمسه مليون مشاهد
هو والدي على فكره بيشتغل يعني انا في ناس
كتير قالت ان هو ممكن يكون فاضي بيوصلك
وكده لا انا والدي شغل الساعه 8 فهو
بيوصلني الساعه سته ويرجع يلبس يروح شغله
كلهم بوديهم يعني
كنت باديها يعني الحمد لله اللي ربنا ادهم
لنا واحنا راضيين بنقسم علينا ربنا انما
ان احنا نفكر يبقى عندنا عربيه دي حاجه
كبيره قوي يعني مش مش
مقدارتنا خالص يعني لا خالص ولا تقدر
نجيبها هي امها وان لم تنجبها فهي التي
ارضعتها طفله واواتها يتيمه ثم احتفلت بها
عروسا ومجازه جامعيه سميره ابكت في حفله
تخرجها والدها المربي المواطنه السعودي
سلطان القحطاني الذي قرر ضمها الى عائلته
عندما اتت بشهورها الاولى الى فان كان
يعمل فيها بعد ان توفي والداها فرحه الحاج
سلطان لا تقل عن فرحه اي اب والد بابنته
سميره ولدت عام 2001 واخذناه وعمرها
تقريبا تسعه شهور كانت تهز السرير تهز
السرير تهز السرير تبكي الى ان تنام
احتملت اني اشوفها صرت اخذها فتره اطلعها
بره وادربها اذا تعلقت تعلقت بي ثم اراد
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان تاتينا
[موسيقى]
طبعا
رضعناها وكان اصغر اولادي في سنها سبب
بكاي انا والله ما العب
على هذا شفت ثمره تعبنا وجهدنا يمشي
امامنا في الميدان
الحمد لله الذي رزقني هذه العائله عشت
معاهم 21 سنه واتزوجت والان عمري 22 سنه
عمرهم ما قالولي لا عمرهم ما فرقوا بيني
وبين اخواني اخواتي
مقطع مؤثر لشاب مصري قدمت طعام لكلبه
وجرائها الام لم تاكل اكتفت بمشاهده
صغارها ياكلون من يد الشاب المحسن
ونظراته شكرها له تروي الكثير
عيالك قمر زيك حبيبي بس يا حبيبي بالراحه
يا حبيبي
تعز عليا قوي قوي قوي على فكره انت توامي
[موسيقى]
اخيرا هناك هجوم مجتمعي كاسح على منصه
التواصل الاجتماعي الصينيه تيك توك
باعتبارها مفتوحه للجيد والسيء للغث
والسمين لكن ككل منصه هي كالسيف بحدين
وتشجيعا منا للمحتوى الهادف سنبرز من وقت
لاخر بعض الذين يخاطبون العقل للغريزه هل
حدث معك او معك انكم تتحدثون الى شخص ما
لمناسبه ما عن رحله صيد سمك موفقه مثلا
قمت بها فبدل ان يستمع الاخر الى تجربتكم
يخبركم انه اصطاد سمك المحيط الاسبوع
الماضي وتسبب بازمه اسماك عالميه
هذا النوع من البشر تصفه مايا مطر في تيك
توك انه نرجسي المحادثه بتقول له انا رايح
هوليدي بقول لك هي انا كنت هناك من جمعه
بتقول له راسي عم يوجعني بقول لك لو تشوف
انا كمان عامل ماي جرين بتقول له ترقيت
بالشغل بقول لك انا كمان رقوني شوف شو صار
معي هودي منسميهم النرجسي المحادثه
قلت لهم بالحديث بيقلبوا الحديث عليهم
وبياخذوا الحديث كله لجهتهم المحادثه
البناء او الصحيه هي محادثه معتدله مبنيه
على تعاون مش على تنافس بين اثنين عم
بيجربوا يعملوا حديث بين بعضهم
[موسيقى]
ختاما يقول شكسبير في نهايه كل يوم تحتاج
الى سله مهملات لكي ترمي فيها كل ما لا
يجب ان يرافقك الى الغد لكن حذاري ان ترمي
فيها ثلاثه من ساعدك في ساعه محنتك ومن
تخلى عنك في اوقات محنتك ومن وضعك في تلك
المحنه قول ينسب ربما خطا لجبران خليل
جبران لكنك اذا طلبت راس الحكمه وكنت قويا
على نفسك قبل الاخرين فذهب الى حديث رسول
الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
اعفو عن من ظلمك وصل من قطعك واحسن الى من
اساء اليك وقل الحق ولو على نفسك الى
اللقاء كل مناعتي وانسامح يسامحنا ربنا
محتاجينه
يسامحنا احنا
[موسيقى]
ناكل
يسامحنا ربنا
محتاجين وسامحنا فعلا
بسامحنا كلنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الجنه قبل
ما مات بس لو نسينا
[موسيقى]